hey guys I don't know if you know or not
but shaycarl is doing this really cool
tag your green road trip now he traveled
all around the United States checking
out really cool green technology and
also meeting some fun youtubers along
the way okay i'm trying to find shaycarl
here the California Academy of Sciences
he is doing this key ecomagination road
trip across the United States and cameo
in one of his videos here he is this
great example of buildings are becoming
more eco-friendly now i'm at Shea in San
Francisco and we took a tour of the
California Academy of Sciences I'm going
to link you up here to shays road trip
videos so be sure to check those out and
now I will leave you with my wonderful
vlog from the day
supply we remove the butter files just
in case you guys didn't know this is the
largest Saphira cool rainforest in the
world yeah that's right I'm a little
butterfly
I barely found shaycarl outside the
rainforest I'm inside the rainforest
we're gonna have an issue stuff
hey guys I just want to say thanks so
much for these delicious foods that I'm
about to consume this place is a great
example of green design from solar cells
to green living roof to their abundance
and skylights throughout the building
in addition to all of their advances in
green technology they also got fantastic
see lights
oh boy hello I'm you know buying your
alligator okay just after swim the tank
here keeping the tank lame you know how
I do ah I found you about you you're so
fast he's hiding from me good to see you
i am in all of its museum looking for
you I've been right here laying on the
floor where's radiant flu lubing floor
to be technology that warms the floor so
is laying on I like 20 kids over there
to lay on it really yes it does no work
don't do it shot taunt the octa-pie it's
octa-pie up to post a link south
purposes no I don't like rookies
earplugs and
I'm gonna go in the loud room
one of the bottom Solaris sleepy
come on a little cutie thanks for
watching hope you like my vlog of the
California Academy of Sciences now be
sure to check out che Carl's road trip
video here and see all of the wonderful
youtubers that he meets along the way
and check out ecomagination on facebook
facebook.com slash week imagination get
over there tag your green leave them a
comment and let them know what your
favorite green innovation is it can be
something that you're doing at home or
something that's going on really cool in
your community I love you guys and I was
talking really fast there ok I'm done
peace